ce dialogue qui commence aujourd'hui
entre nous vous Françaises et Français
qui cherchez en conscience où se trouve
le devoir qui vous interrogez sur ce
qu'il convient de faire pour la France
le 5 décembre prochain et moi candidat
unique de la gauche à la présidence de
la République qui vous demande de
m'écouter et de comprendre pourquoi je
fais appel à vous
oui ce dialogue qui commence aujourd'hui
entre nous je l'espérais depuis
longtemps je suis candidat contre le
général de goulf et contre lui seul car
lui seul compte à
droite mais ce n'est pas une affaire
facile si je l'ai entreprise c'est parce
que je crois de toute ma conviction que
nous sommes à la croisée de chemin le
général de Gaulle se fait certainement
de la France une idée
respectable mais il oublie le plus
souvent de s'occuper des Français or où
en seront les Français dans 10
ans sans déboucher puisqu'on les prive
de l'Europe et puisqu'on casse le marché
commun sans avenir puisqu'on stérilise
notre économie puisqu'on lésigne sur les
crédits de l'éducation
nationale puisque 6% seulement des
filles et des filles des ouvriers et
paysans accéderont au postees de
responsabilité dans notre
société puisqu'il nous faudrait trois
fois plus de chercheurs scientifiques
puisqu'au sortir de l'école des milliers
de jeunes gens iront s'inscrire au
chômage mais cette situation est sans
doute normale si l' mensonge que le
général de Gaulle se pose des problèmes
qui concernaient nos pères tandis que
moi et toute la gauche avec moi j'essaie
de me poser les problèmes qui
concerneront nos
fils je sais bien que le l'actuel chef
de l'État n'ouvre pas la bouche sans
expliquer que ce qui va mal en France
c'est la faute de la 4e République comme
le chantonnai autrefois les mus du
directoire c'est la faute à Voltaire
c'est la faute à
Rousseau mais soyons
sérieux on voudrait tout de même que la
5è République qui a maintenant 7 ans
atteigne enfin l'âge de
raison en
vérité depuis la dernière guerre
mondiale la France n'a pas retrouvé son
équilibre politique et nous sommes allés
d'un extrême à
l'autre sous le régime procéd précédent
le Parlement avait accaparé tous les
pouvoirs la 4e République s'est en Lisée
dans les guerres coloniales
elle a fini dans l'anarchie et personne
ne la
regrette la 5e République elle c'est un
régime propriété personnelle du général
de gaau est-ce tellement
mieux j'ai l'impression que si le chef
de l'État malgré les atteintes de l'âge
veut encore 7 ans de pouvoir c'est
d'abord parce qu'il ne voit autour de
lui et parmi ses amis personne qui soit
digne d'assumer la fonction et c'est
bien ce qu'il voulait dire l'autre jour
lorsqu'il proclamait moi ou le néant
c'est ensuite parce que lui parti il
sait bien que son régime est perdu mais
est enfin je le crains parce qu'il a
cessé de croire dans les chances de la
France je préfère je l'avoue l'attitude
d'un Winston Churchill qui en pleine
gloire et son parti battu adresse s V de
réussite à ses concurrents plus
heureux car au-delà des hommes quel que
soit leur mérite l'histoire continue et
c'est douter de son pays que de se
croire
irremplaçable les républicains par
conviction autant que par tradition
combattent le pouvoir personnel mais
est-il bien sûr qu'en 1965 la majorité
des Français tiraillé par une propagande
de caractère totalitaire et fatigués
qu'ils sont de cette république anonyme
ou plutôt de cette république au mil et
un visages qu'ils ont vu défiler depuis
un demi-sècle est-il bien sûr que la
majorité des Français soit hostille au
pouvoir
personnel certes ce n n'est pas nouveau
on a déjà vu cela dans notre
histoire une république impuissante des
républicains divisés et cela produit
selon le cas un 18 brumèire avec le
premier Bonaparte ou un 2 décembre avec
le
second rien d'étonnant dès lors si le 13
mai
1958 nous a rendu Charles de GA
seulement voilà qu'est-ce que le pouvoir
personnel sinon l'AB par près de 30
millions de citoyens français de leur
destin dans les mains d'un seul homme
sinon l'abdication de la souveraineté
populaire au profit d'un guide
ou d'un
maître c'est parce qu'elle a compris
cela que la gauche pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans s'est enfin
réunie c'est pour cela que pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans la gauche
autour de moi s'est rassemblée
face à une droite dominée sans doute par
la personnalité du général de
Gaulle mais profondément
divisé la gauche contre la
droite peut-être pensez-vous que ces mot
sont bien vieux et qu'il ne signifie
plus grand-chose je vous les abandonne
si nous sommes d'accord sur le reste
c'est-à-dire si nous admettons qu'il y a
dans toute société ce que révolte l'
justice et ceux qui s'en
accommodent ceux qui refusent de changer
par indifférence ou bien par intérêt
quoi que ce soit aux structures du passé
et ceux qui au contraire recherch dans
le présent les chances de l'avenir et
bien moi ce que je vous propose c'est un
choix et un choix dans tous les domaines
extérieur intérieur économique et social
ou bien vous voulez que le général de
Gaulle ou son successeur que vous ne
connaissez pas encore mais qu'il vous
imposera un jour ou l'autre décide de
tout à votre place ou bien vous voulez
décider vous-même et comme tous les
grands peuples du monde qui ont accédé à
la démocratie assumez pleinement votre
fonction de
citoyen mais si vous vous contenter
d'élire une fois tous les 7 ans un
président de la République quitte dans
l'intervalle à le laisser libre d'agir à
sa guise comme un souverain absolu alors
faudra-t-il croire que les Français
s'estiment moins digne ou moins capable
que les Anglais les Américains les
Allemands les Italiens les Suédois que
sais-je encore qui eux exercent
constamment un contrôle sur ce qui les
gouvern mais j'ai dit qu'il fallait
choisir et voici des exemples
fabriqueer la bombe atomique dépenseer
pour elle des milliers de milliards
d'anciens francs comme le veut le
général de Gaulle plutôt que de
construire les écoles ou les logements
dont nous avons besoin comme je le
demande c'est un choix à faire mais qui
vous concerne et qui vous regarde un
seul avion mirage 4 porteur de bombes
atomiques qui sera démodé dans 5 ans
coûte plus cher que 300 logements
HLM refusez comme l'a fait le général de
Gaulle d'arrêter les expériences
nucléaires qui polluent l'atmosphère et
qui frappe dès leur naissance la santé
de nos enfants plutôt que d'inviter le
monde comme je le demande à cesser cette
course infernale au surarmement c'est un
choix à faire mais qui vous concerne et
qui vous regarde s'enfermer comme le
général de Gaulle dans un nationalisme
étroit a sorti d'un jeu compliqué de
coalitions et d'alliances
changeantes qui ont déjà précipité les
peuples au 19e comme au 20e siècle dans
les pires
catastrophes des guerres des revanches
d'autres guerres des vainqueurs des
vaincus jamais les mêmes et pendant ce
temps l'Europe ruinée et les peuples
pantelans plutôt que d'essayer comme je
le fais de bâtir une Europe saine solide
unie ou que de renforcer l'arbitrage
international c'est un choix à faire
mais qui vous concerne et qui vous
regarde imposer un plan dit de
stabilisation qui bloque les salaires
sans freiner les prix qui entretient un
volant de
chômage qui stoppe les sort de notre
industrie comme le fait le gouvernement
de Monsieur
Pompidou plutôt que d'adopter un plan
d'expansion
continue qui assure le plein emploi qui
crée de nouvelles richesses qui dirige
les investissements productifs et qui
fait confiance aux Français dans leur
capacité de travail et de production
comme je le demande c'est un choix àair
mais qui vous concerne et qui vous
regarde le taux des investtis productifs
en France entre 1961 et
1964 0
%. l'Allemagne 16 % lequel des deux pays
dans 10 ans sera le plus jeune et le
plus
riche acceptez que le revenu global de
notre agriculture baisse de 3 % chaque
année que le quart des salariés français
perçoivent moins de 55000 anciens francs
par mois qu'on discute à perte de vue
sur la misérable allocation des
personnes
âgées comme le fait le gouvernement de
Monsieur
pontvideau plutôt que de se battre pour
la justice sociale comme je le fais avec
toute la gauche c'est un choixaffire
mais qui vous concerne et qui vous
regarde acceptez qu'on ne construise que
400000 logements par an quand il en
faudrait 500000 et qu'en même temps on
laisse des fortunes scandaleuse sédifier
sur la spéculation
foncière comme le fait le gouvernement
de Monsieur
Pompidou plutôt que de donner au
gouvernement et aux communes le moyen de
mettre un terme à cette
situation c'est enfin un choix àire qui
vous concerne et qui vous
regarde hier c'était la République des
députés aujourd'hui c'est la République
d'un seul homme demain il faut bâtir la
République des citoyens et c'est pour
cela que je vous disais tout à l'heure
que cel que selon le choix qu'on fait
c'est la droite ou c'est la gauche et
les objectifs essentiels de la
gauche c'est de rechercher dans la
société les moyens de fonder le
bien-être et le bonheur de
l'homme cet objectif impose une
politique extérieure qui soit au service
de la paix impose une politique
intérieure qui soit au service de la
justice mais je n'aperçois ni l'une ni
l'autre au bout de la route que nous
désigne le général de
Gaulle voilà pourquoi je voulais vous
parler
aujourd'hui